>> Greg: EVEN A HURRICANE'S
EMBARRASSED BY VICE-PRESIDENT
HARRIS.
ONCE AGAIN SHE FELL ON HER FACE
BECAUSE SHE MADE IT ABOUT RACE.
IT WAS A WEEKEND OF HARSH
DAMAGING WIND BUT THAT'S WHAT
YOU GET WHENEVER KAMALA IS AT
THE MICROPHONE.
WHILE SPEAKING AT THE DNC'S
WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP FORUM THE VP
MANAGED TO TAKE SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN UNIFYING, A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY CALLED A
HURRICANE, AND OF COURSE MADE IT
ABOUT RACE.
SO CAM WHO SHOULD BE FIRST IN
LINE FOR DISASTER AID?
>> IT IS OUR LOWEST INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED
BY THESE EXTREME CONDITIONS.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS IN A WAY
THAT IS ABOUT GIVING RESOURCES
BASED ON EQUITY, UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE FIGHT FOR EQUALITY BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO FIGHT FOR
EQUITY, UNDERSTANDING NOT
EVERYONE STARTS OFF AT THE SAME
PLACE.
>> Greg: SORRY TO ALL THE
FLORIDA WHITE GUYS.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR FLOODED
LIVING ROOM.
I'M SURPRISED SHE DIDN'T ADD,
GOOD THING WHITE PEOPLE ARE
BETTER AT SWIMMING.
SHE'S A BIGOT.
BUT, HEY, AT LEAST KAMALA'S
GREAT AT LISTING HER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
>> IN YOUR TWO YEARS AS
VICE-PRESIDENT, AND MANY YEARS
OF HOLDING OFFICE IN CALIFORNIA,
WHAT ARE THE MAJOR CHANGES THAT
YOU HAVE SEEN?
>> A LOT OVER THE YEARS.
THERE'S SO MUCH WORK TO DO.  WE
SHOULD APPLAUD THE WORK AT LEAST
WE'VE SEEN RESULTS IN PROGRESS.
>> Greg: BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO ABOUT A VEEP
WHO PUTS THE HER IN DISASTER.
BILL MARCH SAID SHE HAS TO GO
SUGGESTING BUMP HER FROM THE
TICKET IN 2024.
>> ONCE YOU HAVE THAT REAL
ESTATE AND WAKE UP IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND YOUR OFFICE IS THE
OVAL I JUST DON'T THINK YOU GIVE
IT UP.
TAKE THE NOMINATION AWAY FROM
THE PRESIDENT, A SITTING
PRESIDENT, AND WHAT I COULD SEE
IS REPLACING THE VICE-PRESIDENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> BECAUSE, YEAH, SHE'S NOT VERY
POPULAR ANYWHERE.
AND DIDN'T SEEM TO WORK OUT.
>> Greg: WOW.
HIS AUDIENCE APPLAUDED.
IT'S A GREAT IDEA IF YOU'RE
BIDEN.
REMEMBER WHEN ABE LINCOLN GOT
RID OF HANNIBAL HAMLIN IN 18 64.
ALTHOUGH UNLIKE LINCOLN JOE CAME
INTO THE OFFICE WITH BRAIN
DAMAGE.
BUT JOE SAID HE MADE HISTORY BY
HAVING THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN AS
VP AND NOW HE CAN ALSO BE THE
FIRST TO FIRE ONE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: OF COURSE, OF COURSE
LIKE HIS SON, JOE'S NOT ABOVE
USING A WOMAN AND THEN ASKING
HER TO LEAVE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: EMILY, DISGUSTING.
BUT MAYBE INSTEAD OF PUSHING
KAMALA OUT THE DOOR THE ANSWER
IS EVEN SIMPLER.
MAYBE SHE JUST NEEDS MORE
BONGOS.
>> HAVE DESCRIBED RIGHTLY THAT
IT IS OUR LOWEST INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED
BY THESE EXTREME CONDITIONS, AND
IMPACTED BY ISSUES THAT ARE NOT
OF THEIR OWN MAKING.
SO WE --
>> WOMEN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: ALWAYS MAKES IT BETTER.
YOU NOTICE NOW PUSHING OUT THE
WORD EQUALITY AND REPLACING IT
WITH EQUITY WHICH IS BASICALLY
TOP DOWN EQUALITY INSTEAD OF
BOOSTING PEOPLE UP.
IT'S KIND OF SCARY.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> Dr. Saad: I SHOULD FEEL I'M
NOT FEELING TARGETED AGAIN ABOUT
CANADA BECAUSE KAMALA HARRIS
GREW UP IN MONTREAL.
MY HIGH SCHOOL PLAYED AGAINST
HER HIGH SCHOOL, WE'RE ROUGHLY
THE SAME AGE.
I MISSED THE PENALTY SHOT WHEN
SHE WAS THERE.
I BLAME HER FOR IT.
BUT HONESTLY, LET ME MENTION,
WHY I COMMENT ABOUT DIVERSITY
INCLUSION AND EQUITY.
I SAID THIS ABOUT TRUDEAU BUT
I'M NOW GO TO YOUR AS YOU WERE
IT FOR HER.
IF YOU THINK MY 30 YEARS AS A
PROFESSOR ADD UP ALL THE
STUDENTS I HAVE, RANK THE
DUMBEST STUDENTS I EVER HAD,
THAT PERSON WOULD BE ABOUT A
HUNDRED TIMES SMARTER THAN THIS
LADY.
>> WHOA!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Dr. Saad: REGARDING DIVERSITY
INCLUSION AND EQUITY, IT'S NOT
JUST IN THESE TYPES OF CONTEXT,
AT THE UNIVERSITY EVERYTHING IS
NETTED OUT BASED ON DIVERSITY
INCLUSION AND EQUITY.
YOU GET A PROFESSORSHIP BASED ON
IMMUTABLE TRADES.
GRANTS BASED ON IT.
IT'S WHAT MADE THE WEST GREAT
INDIVIDUAL DIGNITY AND NOW WE'RE
LOSING IT ONE INCH AT A TIME.
>> Greg: SCIENCE IS SUPPOSED TO
BE INDEPENDENT OF THAT JOE BUT
INSTEAD IT'S NOT.
WHAT SAY YOU FUNNY GUY?
>> Joe: I THINK WHEN BIDEN SAID
HIS VICE-PRESIDENT, HE SAID SHE
HAS TO BE A BOMB AND SHE HAS TO
BE BLACK AND HE SHOULD HAVE SAID
AND A THIRD THING, THERE SHOULD
ALSO BE A THIRD THING THAT SHE
NEEDS BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY
HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO KICK
HER TO THE CURB.
AND IMAGINE HOW SHE FEELS WITH
PEOPLE LOOKING AT HER AND
SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE THINK THIS GUY'S GOT A BETTER
SHOT THAN YOU AND HE CAN'T GET
OFF THE STAGE WITHOUT A CREW OF
PEOPLE COMING TO HANDLE HIM AND
MOVE HIM AROUND.
IT'S, IT'S REALLY -- THE IDEA
THAT HE WOULD BE REACHING OUT TO
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
THE ONLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES HE REACHES OUT TO IS
THE DECEASED.
AND EVEN DEAD PEOPLE SAY, WE SEE
JOE BIDEN.
>> Greg: YES.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY IN THE POCKET OF
BIG OUIGI BOARDS.
>> Joe: WHAT I DO NOT LIKE IS
THE WORD EQUITY, IT DOES NOT
MEAN ME.
WE WERE HIT BY A HURRICANE IT'S
EASY TO FIGURE OUT WHO NEEDS
HELP AND JUST TO SAY NO IT'S
GOING TO BE THIS GROUP IS AN
UNCONSCIONABLE ACT.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK KAT?
>> Kat: I THINK THIS IS THE
WORST SHE'S EVER LOOKED BECAUSE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IS THE
EASIEST POLITICAL LAY-UP OF ALL
TIME.
NOBODY IS PRO HURRICANE SO HOW
DID SHE STILL MANAGE TO PUSS
PEOPLE OFF WHEN SHE WAS TALKING
ABOUT IT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: IT'S NOT A CONTENTIOUS
ISSUE.
SHE'S SUCH A BAD POLITICIAN.
THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE ONE
THING WHERE SHE SHOULD HAVE DONE
OKAY AND NOPE.
>> Greg: SHE BLEW IT.
I THINK THE BASKETBALL TERM WAS
IT WAS A LAY-UP, YOUNG LADY.
YEAH, I PLAYED SPORTS
>> Kat: I ACTUALLY WROTE THAT
DOWN.
>> Greg: OH, DID YOU?
>> Kat: THAT WAS WHAT I CHOSE
BECAUSE I'M A SPORTS GAL MYSELF.
>> Greg: YES, YES.
EMILY, THE SPORTS GAL HAS
SOMETHING, THIS SHOULD BE A
UNIFYING EVENT AND SHE WAS ABLE
TO TAKE SOMETHING THAT EVERY
AMERICAN PUTS ASIDE THEIR TEAM
SPORT POLITICS AND WORK TOGETHER
AND SHE SAID, NAH, BLACK AND
WHITE.
WOMEN IN MINORITIES HIT HARDEST.
>> Emily: SHE'S LIKE THE WORST
KIND OF DOLL POSSIBLE WHERE YOU
PULL THE STRING AND THERE'S
THREE SENTENCES SHE SAYS AND
THEY'RE ALL UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
NOT JUST UNCONSCIONABLE
LITERALLY UNCON STASHABLE.
[BLEEP] STRAIGHT UP RACIST.
TO YOUR POINT YES ALL AMERICANS
CARE ABOUT ALL AMERICANS.
WE CARE ABOUT AMERICANS IN
DISTRESS AND FOR HER TO COME OUT
OF LEFT FIELD AT THE TIME PEOPLE
LOST EVERYTHING AND LOST FAMILY
MEMBERS AND OUR VICE-PRESIDENT
KNEE JERKS THIS TALKING POINTS
THAT SHE THINKS WILL WIN HER
VOTES BECAUSE SHE IS THE WORST
KIND OF ELITE DEMOCRAT LIBERAL
WHICH IS YOU WILL LISTEN TO WHAT
I SAY, YOU WILL VOTE A CERTAIN
WAY, YOU SHOULD THINK A CERTAIN
WAY BECAUSE OF YOUR SKIN COLOR
AND THEN THEREFORE YOU SHOULD
VOTE A CERTAIN WAY.
SHE KEEPS RAMMING IT DOWN THEIR
THROATS.
I THINK THERE WILL BE A
RECKONING, A HUNDRED PERCENT,
AND THE FACT WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED TO LOSE THE LATE NIGHT
TALK SHOW HOST, THE OTHER ONES,
I THINK IT'S A BIG INDICATOR.
>> Greg: INTERESTING.
PUT THAT IN THERE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE'LL BE INVITED BACK.
UP NEXT, DID THE STRAT